read it do you have bro you have a  brother I'm sure okay do you want only  one though okay is he older or younger  I'm the eldest so yeah he's younger okay  how old how old is John he is 22 22 22.  would you want him to date a girl that  slept with two of his friends  he did oh my god did you encourage you  it happened after they broke up okay it  happened it happened after they broke up  and he was he was it really hurt us yeah  yeah no but I mean I mean what okay wait  so wait let me get this straight he  dated a girl and then she slept with two  his friends afterwards okay so so you've  seen firsthand the damage it can do to a  guy  okay again I don't like this word but um  but it describes you know what I'm  saying no I mean